boutry
da
wesh
la dinguerie la dinguerie
elf héros vous tu te barres mec est le
cheval vador
mais ils entrent mais
je suis dans un cirque je suis dans un
film
allez vas-y la bertauge sur la porte et
se soit 20 ans
ma mère ça ferme sa femme marlène c'est
pour m'excuser j'ai pas fais mes devoirs
ça pour venir vous voir que tu appelles
qu un rappel nathan scott vaches à marle
aisne c'est un vin à table on pleure
ses devoirs pour soi et les valeurs et
jorens hier
chez lui au monde dessert favori
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça veut dire est peut-être avoir des
ennemis qui sont bientôt au cinéma
oui
des triples inc tu avais moi moche et
méchant à vue tous en scène et bal à ces
lignes producteur sauf que ça s'appelle
pêche blanche flèche bleue
et c'est la première fois qu'un film
sans souci une correction n'était comme
ça les gens qui peuvent être co
producteur du film wall et je te dis je
te laisse déjeuner tranquille
maintenant pasqua
[Rires]
1,7
[Musique]
pour du tien
[Rires]
c'est difficile de répondre à cette
question comme ça de but en blanc parce
qu'eric mans il ya beaucoup de sport
très très différents mais s'il ne
fallait vraiment quand choisir un ce
soit sans doute le tennisman rafael le
meilleur joueur je prends une histoire
et surtout celui qui restera comme étant
le plus comment le plus humble non
seulement le meilleur sur le court mais
également le meilleur en dehors du coup